[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir ou bonjour bonjour oui ses
habitudes nous sommes là pour vous
parler d'écologie d'abord fera tête
définir ce qu'est l'écologie
je n'ai vu crois que les gens savent ce
qu'est l'écologie sais pas si on va
faire un test
si quelqu'un ici connaît la définition
d'écologie qu'ils viennent nous a donnés
ici nu avec une plume dans le cul
la personne bon alors écologie science
qui étudie les êtres vivants dans leur
milieu et des interactions entre eux au
même titre que la biologie c'est juste
une discipline scientifique
le mot a été ensuite galvaudé pour
désigner le militantisme de la défense
de l'environnement c'est désormais
l'écologue le professionnel de
l'écologie il n'est d'ailleurs pas
forcément écologistes franchement je
comprend pourquoi ça marche pas super
l'écologie personne ne sait ce que c'est
faut pas s'étonner après regardez là ça
se prétend écolo ça vient assister à des
confins des tables rondes mais c'est pas
fichu de s'intéresser à la base si je
crois qu'ils les avaient que c'est la
même si leur survie en dépend et
écouteront plus ils sont bloqués par
principe et les principes c'est très
pratique pour ne pas avoir écouté
qu'est ce qu'on fait en continu
bon alors voici la grande question
pourquoi la thématique environnementale
n'intéresse pas davantage alors que nos
vies en dépendent
les études et sondages de ces dernières
années démontrent qu'un quart bon quart
de la population française n'est pas
prêt à adopter des comportements éco
responsables et qu'une partie d'entre
eux même se complètement des
problèmes environnementaux
en même temps je les comprends il ya
plein de bonnes raisons ne pas être
écolo doit par exemple être éco
responsable c'est un peu tendre vers la
décroissance il fait peur ce mot un
décroissance acheter moins bouffer moins
voyager - parlons plutôt de sobriété
ménager les ressources de la planète en
somme nous on vit dans une société de
l'avoir rien à voir avec le l'argent à
widnes à voir mais qui combien parmi
ceux qui ont bâti leur leur grade
sociale leur identité sur le fait de
posséder des choses sont prêts à y
renoncer au nom d'une idéologie
révolutionnaire je vois pas moi moi j'ai
un très très bon pouvoir d'achat
je trie mes déchets venez pas me faire
chier ouais mais c'est comme ça pour
être validée par le comité les sauveurs
de la planète tu dois être sobre
j'ai pas des places toit à vélo achète
achète aux producteurs locaux
j'ai pas le temps quelque chose à faire
vous bien je gagne ma vie un na'vi ça se
gagne par celle ci
ouais voilà ça c'est le laïus habituel
un néo hippie bobo vegan op de burnley à
l'isq mélenchonistes francs-maçons qu'au
lac sauvage et je suis sûr je suis sûr
que tu bois ton pipi en cure dépuratives
oui mais non vous voyez toute
possibilité de dialogue est rompu
alors que moi je voulais juste lui dire
qu'ils se trompent qu'il a tort le
convaincre de changer mais qui est prêt
à renoncer à une situation confortable
pour une autre totalement inconnu et
puis on se lève pas à personne cela se
convaincre qu'il a tort c'est une
question d'orgueil qui est prêt à
renoncer au voyage en inde
à la viande aux technologies au luxe
acquis des trente glorieuses comme ça
surtout s'il est pointé du doigt est
traité d'irresponsable je vois pas
pourquoi je prendrais des douches plus
courtes alors qu'ils arrosent des
hectares de green de golf en était un je
vois pas pourquoi je serais zéro déchet
alors qu'on sait très bien que c'est les
industriels les vrais coupables et je
vois pas pourquoi je fais des efforts
alors que la masse autour n'en fait pas
autant pisser dans un violon authentifié
dans une contrebasse autant avoir une
gastro entérite dans un orchestre
symphonique en plus bas j'ai la loi avec
moi et oui aucun texte ne peux
m'empêcher en tant que citoyen en tant
que consommateur d'abuser des ressources
de la planète gelée droit qu'est ce que
je veux et puis franchement à quoi bon
faire des efforts et me chier la vie
alors qu'on sait que c'est trop tard
lenny on nous prévoit un effondrement
d'ici dix ans autant profiter de ce qui
nous reste d'insouciance vous êtes sur
un bateau qui coule avec plein de sex
symbol à bord dans une heure tout le
monde se noie qu'est ce que vous faites
vous nettoyez le pont vous faites une
partouze j'ai été quand on parle de
climat de sixième extinction de masse ne
fonte de la banquise
en fait on est face à des données à des
moyennes à des estimations que notre
cerveau ne parvient pas forcément à
analyser comme des faits concrets or
l'abstrait ça fait pas bouger
on est comme des animaux ont réagi aux
dangers qui sont perceptibles dans une
réalité proche de nous dans le temps et
dans l'espace
un prédateur se pointe je monte dans la
la grande barrière de corail à l'autre
bout du mois on disparaît pas dans
l'immédiat ça va pas me tuer vous voyez
c'est un peu le côté thriller de
l'humanité on a beau dire un fumeur qui
risque de mourir d'un cancer à ce que la
menace d'une maladie futur va le faire
renoncer un plaisir immédiat
est ce que le sort des générations
futures me faire renoncer au dernier
iphone ou bien je me mettrais aux
éoliennes à la clope électronique là où
il est la technologie va nous sauver
elle l'a toujours fait depuis peu les
zones tempérées dans lesquelles nous
habitons son attaque frontalement par le
changement climatique
on l'a vu avec l'ouragan rma et pourtant
nos cerveaux ne parviennent pas à
intégrer cette réalité comme une
conséquence du grand bouleversement à
venir parce que c'est pas le climat
c'est la météo en même temps c'est pas
facile de faire le lien entre ma façon
de faire les courses et le vent qui a
arraché ma toiture
cette distance entre nos comportements
cause et la menace conséquence est un
mécanisme de défense de notre cerveau
qui n'est pas formaté à concevoir des
notions telles que la disparition de
l'humanité
du coup pour faire de la sensibilisation
bas c'est coton c'est un peu comme
expliquer une cirrhose un mec bourré
c'est ça face à la menace avec mathieu
on a identifié quatre grandes catégories
d'humains
la première ce qu'ils n'impactent pas
négativement l'environnement et qui sont
souvent d'ailleurs les premières
victimes de l'expansion de nos sociétés
les sauvages les innocents ce qu'ils
impactent fortement mais qui n'en n'ont
pas conscience qu'ils s'en foutent par
manque éducatif
c'est encore la majorité de nos
concitoyens les imbéciles heureux et à
autant pour moi non oui les aveugles
ceux qui ont conscience de la situation
à perros live donc ceux qui ont
conscience de la situation mais qui sont
pas prêts à changer les hypocrites les
et contradictoires oui et ceux qui ont
conscience de la situation et qu'ils
adaptent leur mode de vie à la prise de
conscience des acteurs du changement
c'est tout
ouais les gros babos qui plane et qui
savent pas le cul
lenny qui tue et stigmatisante ces
gêneurs pour tout le monde ici leur non
seulement ces deux spécimens les les
acteurs du changement et l'autre avant
et les contradictoires qui est le plus
heureux
à votre avis est-ce que c'est celui qui
reste dans la matrice ou celui qui prend
la décision d'en sortir
est-ce que c'est celui qui porte des
ollières et qui poursuit un mode de vie
qu'il c'est néfaste il le sait malgré
son air innocent ou celui qui change ses
habitudes
même si parfois c'est dur nous avant on
était dans cette catégorie est
contradictoire c'est moi avant ça on
avait une conscience écolo mais on a
acheter du jambon sous vide des tomates
au mois de décembre ce genre de truc est
en fait ce paradoxe à nous rendait
malheureux
alors pour être en accord avec nos
valeurs on a décidé de changer de
renoncer à des choses qui nous
paraissaient avant sacré les noëls de
débauche
les voyages en avion à gogo la firme et
vous savez quoi
mais c'est pas si dur en fait bon alors
on est loin d'être exemplaire encore
mais toutes ces contraintes sont devenus
des solutions confortable ces solutions
confortables sont devenus une liberté et
cette liberté là elle nous rend heureux
et ça l'a pu vous le dira pas mais
consommer moins posséder moins c'est bon
pour le moral en plus non seulement un
impact man la planète mais en plus on
peut voir cette expérience comme une
sorte de trading et oui on se prépare à
la fin de l'orgie qui est imminente et
inéluctable on espère faire partie de
ceux qui se laisseront pas surprendre
mais du coup alors si on peut pas
engueulé est pointé du doigt les gros
pollueurs qui s'en foutent encore
comment faire quel mode de communication
adoptée
on a bien vu que la la comme catastrophe
autour de l'écologie pour faire flipper
les gens à bon coup ce n'était pas
l'idéal
ça génère de l'anxiété l'anxiété c'est
pas moteur la paire sclérose voir des
ours polaires décharné des rivières
et ça donne pas envie de bouger ça donne
envie de se réfugier sous la couette
finalement la difficulté c'est c'est de
dire la vérité aux gens sur ce qui se
passe sans les décourager d'agir et
peut-être une bonne solution ce serait
de communiquer positivement sur notre
propre expérience mais nous on fait on
n'a convaincu personne dans notre
entourage avec des mots plus l'on
tentait d'expliquer puis on passait pour
des emmerdeurs alors que pourtant
changer de mode de vie adopté un mode de
vie éco responsable ça nous a été
bénéfique à plein d'égards on a fait des
économies on en meilleure santé on est
plus heureux finalement c'est peut-être
ça le meilleur panneaux publicitaires
mais plutôt que de voir des contraintes
voyons si des opportunités de refonder
le socle de l'humanité on vit quand même
une époque formidable
rendez vous compte on a tous ici la
possibilité de participer au plus grand
est fondamental changement qui est
connue l'humanité et on dirait que tout
le monde s'en tape
c'est bizarre alors oui les écolos
convaincus on reste une minorité
on le sait on se reconnaît à la map on
se fait des petits clins d'oeil en
soirée on est d'accord
pierre rabhi ouais mais on sait qu'on
n'est pas les plus nombreux
cependant ne sous-estimons pas la force
d'un petit groupe qui a décidé de
changer les choses parce que
fondamentalement c'est comme ça que
toutes les révolutions ont commencé mais
finalement on a on a pas on n'a pas
répondu à cette question
non oui comment toucher ceux qui ne sont
pas encore bas ceux qui sont les plus
philo sont sensibles à votre joie de
vivre
ceux qui sont les plus pragmatiques
seront sensibles aux économies qui
peuvent réaliser parce qu'il y en a et
au business peut-être à faire dans ce
nouveau paradigme les plus fiers
réagiront peut-être en constatant que
leur mode de vie les conduit à être des
humains obsolescence programmée et qu'il
est temps de devenir des humains durable
pour les plus anxieux peut-être que
l'effondrement à venir va susciter des
vocations survivalistes parce que
n'oublions pas qu'on est comme dans un
film
ceux qui survivent c'est ceux qui sont
préparés ceux qui sont prêts à
l'entr'aide les autres on peut les
considérer comme des figurants sacrifier
au scénario c'est triste
temps d'en bas ouais en fait on aimerait
bien qu'ils aient une recette magique
mais y'en a pas la vérité en ce qu on
pense en tout cas c'est qu'il ya autant
de façons de convaincre qu'il ya
d'humain
nous on a choisi de rallier à la cause
en faisant des vidéos rigolotes grâce à
l'humour bon vous cache pas que nos
abonnés sont en grande majorité des gens
déjà sensibilisés et que notre humour ce
n'est pas tout le monde attend
maintenant on reçoit un mail comme celui
là c'est comme celui-là cher prof chère
sophy j'ai découvert vos vidéos il ya
quelques mois grâce au temps que vous
employez j'ai pris conscience de la
situation et j'ai décidé d'agir
j'ai réussi à convaincre mes parents et
ma copine de manger moins de jambon de
bayonne
j'ai adhéré à une association qui
nettoie les plages du côté de biarritz
et je tends vers le zéro déchet
merci c'est ces petites victoires ça
nous donne l'énergie pour continuer on
n'a pas tous les mêmes armes pour
convaincre mais individuellement on a
tous une force de conviction qui nous
est propre en prendre conscience c'est
déjà faire un premier pas en dehors de
la matrice l'activé c'est aider nos
congénères à en sortir à leur toit et
c'est comme ça que vous verrez bientôt
on sera plus nombreux que ceux qui s'en
foutent
merci merci
[Applaudissements]